Hi, I'm Phil Sly.
I'm the pastor of Discipleship and Community here at Henderson Hills,
and we're looking at an opportunity for community group certification training.
We're looking at community group through a philosophical, practical,
and passionate approach.
And right now we're gonna be looking at the role of the community group Prayer
and care coordinator.
Ministering to one another is one of the highest purpose and probably one of the
most fulfilling purposes of the community group.
And the group will grow in relational intimacy as they share mutually and
have ex an exchange life experiences and grow with one another in the Lord.
And so,
a loving and caring community group is a unique Christian experience
and way of life.
No other group shares all that a community group shares as it pertains to loving
and caring and praying for one another.
And so it's possible only through God's grace and through the work of Jesus
Christ.
And so we see Christianity being built on the foundation of love and compassion
and service with Christ as our ultimate example.
And so we as believers are called to be ministers and to care for one another.
And when we do that,
we foster Christian community that reflects the teachings of Jesus.
And so we're gonna explore three key issues as it pertains to the prayer and
care coordinator.
We're gonna look at biblical principles that demonstrate the value of prayer and
caring. We're also gonna look practical ways of how to pray for one another and
practical ways of how to care for one another.
So let's first look at these bi biblical principles. Um,
we'll see number one, that love is the foundation of caring.
And we know in John 1334 and 35 that Jesus said,
A new commandment I give to you love one another as I have loved you.
You are also to love one another. And by this,
will all men know that you are my disciples if you have love for one another.
So love lies at the heart of Christian ministry.
And caring for one another flows from this deep wellspring of God's love
for us through Jesus. And so when we minister to one another,
we embody the love of Christ and created a community where genuine
compassion and understanding and support, uh, they just thrive.
And,
and it comes out of this natural outpouring of God's love as we intercede for
one another in prayer,
and as we seek God God's guidance for one another in prayer.
And when we experience God's blessings and God's healings and God's lessons
through prayer. Number two, we wanna look at equipping through prayer.
The Apostle Paul said to the Ephesians,
and he emphasizes different God-given roles,
and he said he gave some to be apostles and some to be prophets and evangelists
and shepherds and teachers for this purpose to equip the saints for the work
of ministry in building up the body of Christ.
And listen to this until we all attain the unity of the faith and the knowledge
of the Son of God to mature manhood to the measure and stature of the fullness
of Christ.
So prayer plays a pivotal role in equipping and nurturing
believers for ministry.
It's through prayer that leaders will seek divine guidance and wisdom and
discernment to serve the community group effectively.
And so we see how intercessory prayer empowers individuals in the community
group find their unique calling in the service of God.
It also fosters unity and maturity within the Christian community.
The community group grows together in their faith. Uh, lastly,
a believer in Jesus is equipped for works of service when that person is
cared for or cares for others within the community group.
When the body of Christ is properly cared for,
the result is unity and maturity and knowledge in the son of God.
Number three, scriptural proof is that prayerful, uh,
talks about prayerful acts of genuine love. Paul, in his letter to the Romans,
uh, offers this practical aspect of Christian care. He says,
let love be genuine. Ab bore what is evil. Hold fast to what is good,
love one another with brotherly affection and outdo one another in showing
honor. Do not be slothful and zeal, but be fervent in spirit and serve the Lord.
Listen to this, rejoice and hope.
Be patient in tribulation and be constant in prayer.
Contribute to the needs of the saint, and seek to show hospitality.
So prayer is inseparable from genuine love. It,
it actually characterizes real genuine Christian care.
When we pray for one another, we lift up one another's burdens before God,
and we share in one another's sorrows and joys.
So prayer cultivates empathy. It fosters a deep sense of connection,
and it is through these prayerful acts of service that we demonstrate Christ's
love. Number three, we look at shepherding through prayer.
In the early Christian Church,
Peter addresses the role of the leader within that community and encouraged them
to be humble. Shepherds, he says, shepherd the flock of God that is among you,
exercising oversight, not under compulsion, but willingly as God would have you,
not for shameful gain, but eagerly not domineering over those in your charge,
but being an examples to the flock. And when the chief shepherd appears,
that's capital ss Jesus himself, when he appears,
you'll receive an unfading crown of glory.
So prayer is a vital tool for Christian leaders to watch over and to care
for their community group. And through prayer,
they seek divide to shepherd the flock that God has entrusted to him,
to them with wisdom and humility and compassion.
They intercede for the needs of their community group,
and they foster a culture of spiritual growth and healing and unity and,
and thankfulness. Uh,
Christian ministry is a divine call to love and serve and care for one another,
just like Christ did for us.
And so we're inspired by Jesus' teachings and by the guidance of the biblical
passages.
And we understand the indispensable role of prayer in our ministry and in our
leadership. See,
I believe that prayer is the lifeline that connects us to God's grace and power
and enables us then to intercede and to seek guidance and to serve one another
with genuine love and real compassion.
So through these prayerful acts of service,
a Christian community group becomes a beacon of hope and a demonstration of
just transformative power in Christ's love in the world.
So let's look now at these last two things,
practical ways for a community group to pray for one another and practical ways
for community group to care for one another. Let's first talk about prayer.
So a community group understands the necessity to refuse this prayer time,
to refuse to gossip or to cast blame or to shame one another,
to be judgmental or criticize people. Rather,
they are being genuine and transparent and vulnerable when they're making
prayer requests. And so they're to be treated with a degree of sensitivity.
And having discretion and permission to share prayer requests is essential.
I wouldn't just post everything you hear without permission.
So you get permission to share prayer requests to the entire community group,
and you're discreet about those.
Sometimes you have to rewrite them so that their sensitive information is sent
out publicly. And if you have questions, if it's too sensitive to send,
then rephrase it or just choose not to send it. Just, uh, make it a, uh,
an anonymous prayer request, if you will. Uh,
so you collect these prayer requests from the community room at a time that's
agreeable to the director and the teacher. Uh, one of the problems that's, uh,
been just a,
a a significant problem for a lot of community groups is the prayer time goes
long. And as a result, then there's very,
very little time for studying the scriptures together.
And that's frustrating for the teacher because he or she has prepared that time
and now has only got 10, 15 minutes to, uh, to present that. And so it,
it's always a problem.
And so here are a few ideas for collecting and distributing prayer requests. Uh,
my community group,
we pass around three by five cards at the beginning of the group.
And then before the end of the group,
we ask our prayer and care coordinator to collect those cards.
And then they're responsible for distributing those prayer requests. And so, uh,
another thing you can do is on the whiteboard just to ask community group
members to write their prayer requests down, uh, on the board. And, uh,
in doing so,
then maybe later you'll have an opportunity to break into small groups to pray
for the requests that have been listed on the whiteboard. Another idea,
especially for our younger groups, is to use technology to gather requests.
My group uses GroupMe.
We collect them by three by five card within the prayer and care coordinator
will post them on GroupMe, which everyone receives on their smart device.
And everyone gets notification that they've been called to pray. Uh,
I've seen other community groups who will use a Q card, uh,
a QR code that will take them to a, a Google form, which, um,
then will go to everyone who's agreed that sometimes, uh, the people will use a,
uh, uh, email groups to send out, uh,
prayer requests and, and, uh,
or maybe even a prayer blog or a private Facebook page to distribute these
prayer requests. Uh,
one thing I'm going to ask those of you who use emails to do is this, uh,
for security and for privacy reasons,
it's best practices to paste the email addresses in the blind carbon
copy section. And, uh,
especially when you're sending it out to a very large community group.
And when you do that,
then those addresses are not visible to the recipients of the email. Uh,
I don't know if this has happened to you, but it has happened to several, uh,
people that I know, that people has used those lists to actually farm business,
uh, uh, their business. And it's, it's not what, not what it's intended for. So,
um, give everyone a blank note card as they enter the room,
ask 'em to write down their prayer request and then redistribute those cards,
um, so that people will have someone to pray for for them every week. Uh,
one last thing that I want us to talk about is, uh, family rules. Now,
family rules are a very, uh,
helpful way of providing some time boundaries for prayer requests.
And so what you can do for family rules is ask your community group to only
present prayer requests for people that live in their home or have lived in
their, their home, or have once lived in their home. Uh,
community group prayer requests can go really, really long.
Whenever we start praying for neighbors, uh,
family who live somewhere that no one has really heard of before,
those doesn't mean we shouldn't pray for those things,
it's just that they're not as important as family rule prayer time.
So let's also look at the way a community group can care for one another. Uh,
we're going to ask you as a prayer and care coordinator to utilize the community
group leadership team to create a culture,
a culture of celebration and love whenever there's, uh,
something to be celebrated, uh,
community group members know that they're cared for.
If the community group celebrates with them and stands with them in the time of
trouble and crisis, let's first look at celebration and love.
A healthy Christian community is characterized by a sense of belonging. And so,
uh,
community group members share a measure of empathy during times of both trouble
and crisis, but also celebration and love.
And we're gonna talk about celebration and love. Uh, Romans 12,
15 through 18 says,
rejoice with those who rejoice and weep with those who weep.
Live in harmony with one another. Do not be haughty,
but associate with the lowly and never be wise in your own sight,
but repay no one evil for evil.
But give thought to those who do what is honorable in the sight of all if
possible, as far as it depends on you live peaceably with all.
So what does it mean to love our community group members? Well, number one,
I think you need to know them. Know their names,
know their spouses and family members know their careers and their hobbies,
their likes and their dislikes. Know when they're absent from the group. Uh,
I think it's very noble of a community group to decide that we're going to be a
group that chases the strays. If someone doesn't show, uh,
maybe if you don't know where they are, um, give them a text and ask them. Say,
Hey, we missed you. Is everything okay? Um,
what you're trying to do is providing for the spiritual needs of those in your
group by, um, having a,
a belonging sense of group interaction where we affirm one another,
where there's mutual rejoicing and,
and sincere em empathetic responses and kind of a reciprocal
honor among group members. And so we,
another thing we can do is we can seek practical ways to serve one another. Uh,
Jesus said in Matthew 2026 through 28 said, uh,
it shall not be like that among you,
but whoever would be great among you must be your servant.
And whoever must be first among you must become your slave.
Even as the son of man talking about himself, Jesus said, he,
I didn't come to be served,
but to serve and to give my life as a ransom for many. So, uh,
Jesus is showing us that we build relationships in our groups
by showing one another how we love one another.
And that oftentimes must happen apart from the group meeting. Uh,
share lunch with one another after church, send cards or texts or emails,
uh, pay close attention to group members that are not there that miss
meetings. Uh,
and then another thing you can do is share resources for those who are in need.
Uh, people who are, um,
have family members who are in the hospital or who may be out of work,
I would say, uh, provide meals for them. There's so many ways to do this now.
I used to, you'd have to take food by,
but now there's Uber Eats and GrubHub and gift cards and those kinds of things.
And, and so, uh, uh, I,
I've made it a habit for sometimes when people are really struggling,
it's just to pick up a pizza on the way home and deliver it,
or bringing groceries or even some sort of a dessert or flowers or treats or
whatever, uh, offer to provide transportation. Uh, uh,
my next door neighbor one time, uh, was in a, in a bad way,
and I just decided that I, whenever I mowed my lawn, I'd mow his lawn.
It wasn't a very large lawn, but it's just an opportunity to show Christ's love.
And, uh,
another thing you could do is watch the kids or maybe visit an an elderly, uh,
parent. Uh, acts 2 45, uh, 45 says,
and they were selling their possessions and belongings and distributing the
proceeds to all as any had need. And day after day,
attending the temple together and breaking bread in their homes,
they receive their food with glad and generous hearts,
praising God and having favor with all the people.
And look what happens as a result of them sharing mutual love and honor,
and the Lord added to their number daily, those who are being saved.
So, uh, we as community group leaders,
and you specifically as a prayer and share, uh, prayer and care coordinator,
uh, need to,
to make an effort to share in the celebration of notable stages of
life, change significant milestones,
events like birthdays and anniversaries, maybe the birth of a child, baptism,
the marriage, empty nesting retirement,
any significant life change couldn't be celebrated by your community group.
And in doing so, you're shepherding and caring for members,
and they know that and they feel loved. Now, the second way that you, uh,
show someone love and care is during trouble.
And crisis community groups minister to one another during emergencies,
during crises by shepherding and caring for one another. And, uh,
sometimes shepherding and caring are words that are used synonymously in
Christian language, but by definition it means to tend to,
or to guard and to lead much like a shepherd does in caring for a sheep.
So a shepherding a church member is providing loving care and, uh,
nurture and spiritual guidance, emotional support,
even financial assistance and physical aid when there's a need.
The most effective way of providing biblical shepherding and caring is through
intentional decentralization. Now,
I know decentralization is not a biblical word,
but it describes exactly what we're trying to do in a large church.
Decentralization is the deliberate decision to disperse or distribute the
role of shepherding and caring among the church. Um,
if we relied upon our lead teaching pastor to do all the shepherding and
caring, most of us would feel like we hadn't had enough care and share.
So what he's done now is decentralize the effort of
shepherding to community group leaders.
And what I'm asking you to do as the community group prayer and care coordinator
is to take that role of decentralizing the care and shepherding
and and distributed among your group. And in doing so,
we know that everyone will be taken care of,
but there will be opportunities whenever there's an issue that arises in your
group that might go outside of the scope of your community group to tend to
alone. And so at that point,
we're gonna ask that you share that burden of the responsibility and shepherding
and caring with the elders and the deacons and the paid ministerial staff. Uh,
we have committed as a leadership group in the staff to be, uh,
to come alongside our members in mobilizing and equipping and empowering and
supporting a community group leadership to care for people in time of need,
but also come alongside them when that burden is too great. Um,
in a large and growing church like Henderson Hills,
the elders and the deacons and the ministerial staff and the community group
leaders must partner together to shepherd God's flock.
And as the church grows even larger, the more necessary, uh,
the more useful, the more effective the leadership,
the community group's going to be in becoming quality shepherds who care for and
love the flock. Um,
also when we talk about caring for members facing trouble in crisis, um,
we need to understand that, uh, that,
that there are a number of times when people fully expect to be contacted by
those who love them. A physical illness, a career crisis or job loss,
uh, marriage or family strife. Uh, the death of a loved one. Uh,
I was so proud of our staff yesterday because one of our, uh,
part-time staff's mother passed away unexpectedly. In fact,
we had prayed for her just, uh, the Tuesday prior to her passing on Thursday.
And, uh, just yesterday, almost the entire staff came to the funeral.
And we had not had an opportunity to meet her mother, but that didn't matter.
We know her and we love this staff person.
So we came alongside her as her community. Um,
community group members who share in the suffering, uh,
often do so during times of unexpected crisis,
like emergency room visits or hospitalizations or surgeries or,
uh, serious medical procedures. And, um, they understand that,
that there's almost a triage process where leadership has to determine urgency
and attention. And so, uh,
at what level do we need to provide shepherding and care?
Do I need to get up out of bed and get to the hospital,
or is this something that can wait till the morning? So, um,
here are the groups that come together for decentralization,
for sharing the opportunity and the privilege of shepherding and caring for one
another. There's community groups and first and foremost,
but there's also ministry groups. I know that our, uh,
not only our discipleship and community,
but our kids' ministry and our youth ministry and our worship ministry,
they're all very involved in caring for one another,
but also discipleship groups.
We have a women's mentoring and men's radical mentoring,
and we have micro groups. And this also includes our, uh,
our elders and our deacons and our ministerial staff. Uh,
I know our Celebrate Recovery groups do a great job in supporting one another
and also ministries of Jesus comes alongside and provides all kinds of care that
people might not have, uh, if they did not have the kind of, uh,
resources that some have. So, uh, let's talk about this in conclusion.
Your role as a community group prayer and care coordinator is crucial
for the life of your community group and for the hurting in your community
group. And as you shepherd and care for these people,
you're encouraged to minister to them towards the love of Christ and for the
gospel. And if you do so, you are embodying Christ's love for the church,
and you're becoming the disciple by this Will Allman know that you're my
disciples because you have love for one another.